alexandre une première question plutôt
personnelle mais en tant qu il dînera
comment vivez-vous le confinement la
couleur un peu compliqué que je n'oublie
famille avec deux enfants dont un petit
garçon d'un an
donc c'est pas forcément évident fait
adapté il ya le télétravail aussi j'en
avais jamais drame ont fait fait la
première fois donc la tentation c'est au
jour le jour
voire à leur faveur donc écouter on sent
faible ap
enfin là et commence et adapter le
travail de la rédaction parce que le
métier de journaliste est un métier de
terrain avant tout c'est compliqué il a
fait un bouclage normal ma vie mardi
matin on a une conférence de rédaction
avec nos chefs avec notre directeur pour
voir comment on allait faire organiser
on a dû subir globalement qu on allait
tout faire du télétravail et que on
allait maintenir le site internet
qu'elle soit 118 actuel puis notre
journal papier qui paraît tous les
mercredis avec une pagination réduite
on va essayer donc de maintenir le
journal mercredi prochain avec au lieu
de faire une édition par secteur c'est à
dire une édition pour versa une mission
pour rambouillet une édition pour mende
et une édition pour saint germain en
laye on va faire une édition commune en
fait vous tous les journaux des yvelines
vont contribuer dans le journal de
versailles on trouva du menton 3 du
saint germain on trouvera du poids si
autrefois du rambouillet on voit là on
s'adapte et comme tu as pour ce qu'ils
comme ce qu'il souhaite
on va encore essayer de faire encore
quelques reportages
par exemple moi j'étais ce matin sur le
marché ne mord pas où je fais un
reportage sur le marché qui continue à
vivre malgré le grenaillage alors quelle
est la suite pour votre journal on
maintient les publications on les réduit
je vous dis qui n'a publié lundi dans un
incertain du conte qui essaient de faire
une article le cliché veut en récupérant
des photos des éléments de problèmes et
pas toujours évident on va continuer à
faire des reportages quand on peut par
exemple les conseils municipaux
d'installation des nouveaux maires on va
essayer d'y assister
même si certains sont à duclos ou si on
essaiera de les faire qu'il ya internet
une boucle à tous comme ça mais c'est
vrai que là c'est vraiment au jour le
jour là en effet déjà de faire une belle
édition une édition pour mercredi
prochain visera un petit exploit
et puis la semaine suivante va on va
voir comment on va faire